>> So, what, how do you start with this now, Charles?
>> Okay, so the first thing I'm going to do is,
I'm going to look at the first two examples. And the
reason I'm doing that is because I know they both
generate true. And so I'm going to look for variables that
are inconsistent. So if I look at X1, for example,
it's a one in the first case, and a zero
in the second case. So it can't be the case
that it's required in order for this to be true.
And the same would be true for x3. So I'm going to say that neither x1 nor x3
matter. By contrast, x2, x4, and x5 all
have the same values in both of those cases.
>> So we don't know much about them quite yet.
>> No
>> But let's so let's, that seems very well reasoned. So we
know that x1 can't be part of this formula and x3 can't
be a part of this formula. So, let's just sort of imagine
that they're not there cause they don't really give us any information
any more.
>> Beautiful.
>> Alright, So what's left?
>> So what's left is now to make certain that x2, x4 and x5 are
necessary, and particularly necessary with the, the values
that they have. So I guess all I
can really do is see if there's anything
else to eliminate. If I were just looking
at the first two, I would think that the answer was not X2, X4, not X5.
>> Alright. so, hang on, not X2, X4, not X5.
>> Right. So, that's what I currently think it is based upon what I just saw.
>> And that would be, that's consistent with the first two examples.
>> Right. And so, now I want to make certain is consistent with the
next three examples. This is the easiest way for me to think about
this, anyway. So, let's see. Not X2, X4, so that should be false, which it is.
They're all false, so let's see not X2. But x4,
up, that should be false, which it is. And then I do that
same thing. But wait, why isn't that the answer? That can't be the answer.
>> Is the answer you got it.
>> Huh I got it right.
>> So the thing to notice is that in these first two examples
we have X2 is false X4 is true and X5 is false and that's
enough to make the conjunction true but making. Flipping any one of those
bits is enough to make it false so what I showed in the in
the remaining examples is that just by turning this
X2 into an X1 leaving everything else the same
we lose it. Similarly if we flip the X4
to zero and leave everything else the same, we
lose it. Similarly if we flip x5 to one,
and leave everything else the same, we lose it.
So that means that each of these is necessary
to make the conjunction. They're all actually in there.
>> That's just what I was thinking. So, in
other words, you gave me some positive examples to
eliminate things that were necessary, and then you gave
me negative examples to validate that each of the variables
that I saw so far were necessary because getting rid
of any one of them, gave me the wrong answer.
>> Exactly. Let's, let's even write down those
two steps. So the first thing was show
what's irrelevant. And how many questions How many
queries might we have needed to show that?
>> Well, one per variable.
>> Well actually we only need two because
what I did is I, I used, all the relevant ones I
kept the same and all the irrelevant ones I flipped from one
to the other. I just have to show you that it's still,
the output is still one even though they have two different values.
>> Oh, no, no. When I said all of them, you know, k of
them was because I didn't know that, what if all of them were irrelevant
>> Then it would still be two. because then I
could just show you the all zeroes, and the all ones.
>> You're right. You're right. You just
need, oh that's right. That's exactly right.
>> Alright. And
then I have to show you that the, that
each, the remaining variables is relevant by flipping it
and showing you that the answer is zero. And
how many questions did I need to do for that?
>> Three.
>> Yeah, three in this case cause there were three variables
that were used in the formula. What's the most it could be?
>> Well k, cause all of them could be relevant.
>> Yeah, so it's you know, it's kind of interesting that, that
in fact the total number of hypothesis here is three to
the K. Because you know, you can see it right
off this table that for each of the variables, it's either
positive, absent or negated. But the number of questions that a
smart teacher had to ask was more like, K plus two.
>> Huh.
>> Which is pretty powerful.
>> Right, so. The smart teacher can help me
do this in linear term. So what if I
were, I, I didn't have the teacher who could
give me these examples and I always had to ask?
>> That's a good question, let's let's do that.